How do you learn languages when you're
not in the country where the language
is spoken or the languages are spoken?
I think that's the
situation for many of us.
To speak well, usually
we need to speak a lot.
That's been my experience in most cases.
However, I'm gonna introduce you
to someone today who speaks a wide
variety of languages, remarkably well,
and she's learned them all at home.
Iclal From Turkey.
I think you'll find this very interesting.
Hi, today I have a special guest.
It's Iclal from Turkey, who is a
wonderful polyglot, a young polyglot.
Hi Iclal.
Hi.
So, uh, one, first of all, if you
enjoy my videos, please uh, subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications.
If you're following me on a uh, uh,
podcast service, please leave a comment.
So I, I'm really happy to have
here for a number of reasons.
First of all, because she
is a wonderful polyglot.
We had a conversation on her
channel in different languages,
uh, because she's from Istan...
I don't know her actually,
if she's from Istanbul.
She will tell us.
She's from Istan.
And uh, and then I wanna talk a
little, because I haven't talked
to that many polyglots from Turkey.
Maybe there are a lot.
I just haven't met them.
And so I'm gonna, we're gonna have a
bit of a conversation about the role
of geography in language learning,
but first I would like to ask Iclal to
sort of introduce herself, explain her
interest in different languages, why
she learned them in different languages.
Can you do that for us Iclal?
I guess.
Give it a try.
So, uh...
yeah.
Um.
No, I'm just saying that again.
Yeah, that was all.
Wonderful, wonderful, wonderful.
Um, you know, I, uh, I'm very
impressed with your ability
to speak these languages.
Uh, your pronunciation, your grammar.
So, uh, before we get into this
theme of geography, I, I wanted to
ask you, for example, I noticed that
your cases in Russian were very good.
How did you go about learning...
and of course in German too, as
you said, both those languages
have somewhat complicated grammar.
How did you go about learning the,
uh, grammar in those languages?
So, I think I have a dis...
so I think I have a different perspective
of grammar because some people are
really, ignoring when it comes to grammar.
They say that it's not useless.
No, they say that it's not useful at
all, but actually I have another opinion.
I find grammar pretty useful, and grammar
actually helped me a lot while I was
learning those, uh, Italian and Spanish.
But sometimes I realize that I pay
way too much attention to grammar.
For example, in Russian,
that's what I did.
I learned only grammar and nothing else.
Actually, right now, my
grammar is nearly perfect.
But, um, doing that actually
wasn't really a good choice.
I, maybe I had to listen to more
Russian, I had to speak more, but
yeah, I know that my grammar is okay
because, um, there was a time where I
studied only grammar and nothing else.
But I think that grammar is...
like you should pay attention to
grammar, but only at a necessary amount.
And if you just exaggerate the attention
that you uh, give to grammar, then
everything becomes complicated as
what I experienced with Russian.
I just, I just hate the
language because of the grammar.
But for example, with German, I just
learn to grammar regularly without paying
too much attention to it, but at the
same time without ignoring the grammar.
So I think that you should somehow just
keep the balance between grammar and
other skills, and that's how I just
manage speaking in a true way, let's say.
Now the, I I thought about this today.
You know, this, this
question of geography.
So, uh, apparently in Ethiopia people
are, uh, multilingual because there's
so many different languages in Ethiopia
or if you live in Luxembourg, you are
surrounded by many different languages.
Uh, if you live in the United States,
uh, or even in most of Canada,
you've got no one to speak to in any
other language other than English.
Uh, for example, the Spaniards
are not as good as the Portuguese.
The Portuguese are a smaller country.
Uh, you know, Russia is a large country.
I don't know how good they are
at speaking languages or Japan
where I live for many years.
Uh, I don't think the language
skills are that great.
Uh, I don't know what the situation is in
Turkey, but to what extent do you think
that your location, physical location,
in today's day and age with the internet
and so forth, how much does that affect
your language learning possibilities.
Yeah, good question.
I think so actually I live in Turkey, and
Turkey is a really multicultural country
and it's becoming this every other day.
Like we have a lot of tourists
and we have a lot of people
who start living in Turkey.
And because of all these reasons, like
it's really easy to find an international,
uh, uh, environment here in, in Turkey.
Just if I, just specifically European
coast, I would just find a lot of
tourists to talk to, especially
Russians, people who come from
Arabic countries, Spanish people.
Yeah.
I think right now we have a lot of
possibilities, but, uh, what I'd like to
mention is that I have a lot of polylglot
friends, which are particularly from
Europe, they live in European countries
and uh, they're also polyglots like
me, but I have a really different thing
that actually makes me, um, Kind of
different than them because people are
just like, I was born in that country
and my mother was actually bilingual,
and then I studied in that country.
Then we moved to that country
so I learned that language too.
And I was at Spain and all holidays I
went to Italy, I went to France, but
I actually have been abroad only once.
And that was a country that
I didn't speak the language.
So I think...
Which country was that?
The Netherlands.
Right now I'm learning the language,
but when I visited there, back
then, I didn't speak the language.
So I have never been to France.
I have never been to Russia.
I don't know where, when I'm going
to actually visit these countries.
That's another question.
So I think that, uh, That's the
main thing that differentiates
me from other polyglots.
And maybe that's the thing that makes me
inspirational because people say that,
okay, maybe it's possible to learn all
these languages when you stay in your own
country and don't visit just overseas.
But I think that if I was born in a
European country, maybe I would have more
opportunities to learn all these languages
and maybe that would be easier for me.
But also in Turkey, I think that...
yeah, as long as you haven't
true that connection, I think
you can learn everything.
The country doesn't play a big role
here, but the importance of Turkey
in my language learning is that,
is that we have a lot of tourists.
I think like I can just easily
find native speakers or...
I just meet other polyglots who come
to visit Turkey because we have a lot
of tourist destinations and people just
want to, um, witness all this history.
Do, do you spend a lot of time
speaking with these people?
Yeah,
actually when, whenever I just, uh,
visit the European coast because it's
kind of a more tourist place, then the
place where I live right now, I live in
Asia, so there are a lot of toursits and
they're most likely eager to help you.
And actually...
When you say European coast,
what are you referring to?
You not mean like İzmir or Antalya?
No, no,
no.
Actually I don't mean that.
Istanbul has, uh, two continents.
Oh, the European
side of Istanbul?
Yes.
So Istanbul has two sides and the European
one is kinda the place the tourists...
More international.
Yeah.
So whenever I talk to tourists
they're just really kind.
They're eager to help
me, especially Russians.
I think they're just like, when they see
that you speak Russian, they are surprised
and they just want to talk to you.
They ask you a plenty amount of questions.
I think that Turks and Russians
just share this thing when we see a
foreigner who speaks our language.
We're just amazed by that.
I think that's really incredible.
I can tell you, I can tell you
that the, uh, the, we have a lot
of Iranians here in Vancouver.
If I speak to them in Persian that
they're just, they're just so happy.
It's, they're the most positive
I have ever come across.
We also have a lot of Iranian here
about, I don't speak their language.
Right.
Yeah.
So in other words, what you're
saying is that geography, so it
helps in a way because you have a
lot of foreigners, visitors there.
Uh, if you lived in Ankara, then
presumably it would be more difficult.
Now how much do you talk on the internet?
So actually I have...
Or is it mostly people you meet in person?
No, actually
I use internet more because, uh, I can,
um, just find more people on internet
and I have more options to talk to
because when you see someone, just when
you prefer meeting someone to have a
language exchange with them, that can
be sometimes real difficult because of
the scheduling, because of planning.
I don't know.
It's not really possible
to do that regularly and...
yeah.
But on the internet, actually,
we can talk to everyone, uh,
in each part of the world.
So I prefer talking to people on internet.
How do you do that?
Uh, is this language exchange
or who do you find to
talk to?
So sometimes I talk to my followers
because sometimes they say, hello
Iclal, I'm from Russia and I'm
learning Turkish so if you like,
Uh, I could help you in Russian and
you can just help me with Turkish.
So I just accept that
and we become friends.
Actually, some of my friends are
just, some of my friendships are
just like created like that from
my followers because we just have
a language exchange with them.
Or on the other side, I can also
name some, uh, language learning
applications like Tandem, Hello
Talk also on these kind of things
we can find other people to talk to.
And there is a website that
I'd find really useful, which
is Conversation Exchange.
I have ha, I have found many
friends on this website.
So...
conversation exchange.
Okay.
Internet actually offers us
everything needed, and I think
that everyone who wants to learn
languages must actually use that.
But
how do you get yourself to a
level where you can actually
have a meaningful exchange?
Say you start in a language from scratch.
Now how are you gonna get to where you can
actually have an exchange with someone?
So actually I don't really prefer, uh,
talking to natives at the very beginning
because you don't have something to say.
You just say, hello, how are you?
My name is, I speak those languages.
And you have the same
conversation with everyone else.
And at this point, actually, you think
that you are having a proper conversation
with someone, but actually what you're
doing is just repeating yourself and
you're, you're not learning something new.
You're just learning the greetings, but
you know, already learned them before.
So what I think is that, We should
start speaking to native speakers
when we are at A2 or B1 level.
For example, I have met a Russian
friend last year, and at the beginning I
couldn't really have a conversation with
him because my Russian was really poor.
But after he said that,
just tell me everything.
You can just form a sentence
using the words you know.
And after a month, I actually was at the
level of having a proper conversation
with him, and that's amazing, I think.
So we should just wait until A2 or
B1 and then we should do our best.
So while
you're waiting, what do you do
then in if with these languages?
Say you're waiting, you're not
yet, you're waiting to, how do
you get yourself to the A2 B1
level?
So actually I'm just grabbing the
basics because if you don't have the
basics in that language, it's, it's
actually kind of difficult to speak.
For example, imagine that you're speaking
Italian and if you don't know past tense,
if you don't know future tense, if you
don't know the personal pronouns, actually
it's impossible to speak to someone.
So once you get the basics from a
material from a particular thing uh,
you say, okay, I have completed A1, I
have completed A2, and then right now
I can start talking to native speakers.
So at that level, when I feel that
I can construct a few, um, a, that
field was driven a few phrases
in languages, so then I start for
native speakers and I talk to them.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Well, I think your example
is, uh, is very encouraging.
Uh, for someone who is, uh, not in
the country where the language is
spoken, and yet you've achieved a very
high level in, in those languages.
And, uh, I think that's a good
example for, for people who
are interested in language.
I hope.
People...
yeah.
So, and, and, uh, especially at such an
a young age to speak so many languages
so fluently, I'm most impressed.
So thank you very much...
you're welcome.
For taking the time to
visit with me today.
It  And, uh, I will leave a link
to your, uh, YouTube channel in the
description box, and, uh, they can watch
us, uh, speak in different languages.
Uh, I know that you have also used
LingQ, and I don't know if you still
are using LingQ, but, uh, I think that's
one of the tools that you find useful.
Yes.
But of course there's only one among
many tools and I think people have to go
and find, whether it be the conversation
exchange or find their own method in their
own way to, you know, ways of learning
languages that they find enjoyable.
Of course.
Which obviously you do.
And if you do that you
will continue to improve.
Absolutely.
So thank you.
You're welcome.
And one day I'll learn enough Turkish so
we can have a conversation in Turkish.
Hopefully.